the brothers are asking how do I know on
the marriage night how can I tell if
she's a virgin and the sisters will ask
how can I hide it
because I have committed sin I have
committed sinner sister what does that
mean
why does a woman's past matter Sharia
but what about like spiritually a man
who slept a lot around spiritually I
don't think he's going to be any
healthier than the woman has no that's
not sorry that's not true that's not
true on a spiritual level no that's not
true no no I'm saying on a spiritual
level of course not true but can you
answer in the question within that yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's what for me yeah
it wouldn't be a problem for me yes but
you might be better than many many
sisters out there yeah you don't see so
so you're contradicting what you just
asked no no no you just said you just
said you wouldn't accept the sister
what I'm saying is this the consequences
are not the same so I do think the
responsibility lays on men to stop
perpetuating that a woman is stained
when she has Sinners she's got 30
seconds
foreign
[Music]
we want to establish an amazing Masjid
for the sake of Allah in the country of
Norway click on the link and donate now
for the sake of Allah
welcome to the another episode of The
Bitter truth we're here to inshallah
derive some truths from our guests
inshallah from Quran and the Sunnah and
today's topic is I'll introduce you to
the bitter buzzers the bitter buzzers
are you know if you want to say
something you feel very passionate about
press it you have a minute and a half to
talk everyone listen to inshallah
um you only have one chance to press
that today's topic is does a man judge a
Woman by her past and does a woman judge
a man by his future
so let me ask the sisters the question
oh should we all right let's start off
with the first one does a man judge a
Woman by her past yes
okay can we can can you tell me why you
gave some emphasis to shut down those oh
yes oh because very simple
um
men men uh have some insecurities two
two types of insecurities I learned that
I'm a good teacher
um
also like men are very very um they want
to know
a lot of things about the female if
she's been with somebody uh she's ever
had a boyfriend her earlier life uh you
know how she lived her early life so
yeah they do yes I'm so excited to stop
you just to give a disclaimer yeah
because the thing is we want this to
help marriages not destroy marriages
if you're watching this and I need to
because I think this way it will answer
the question of the sisters and they'll
understand us men better if you're a
brother
and you are married to a sister you may
have a past please if it's going to
affect you do not watch this I'm telling
you because something this can cause
divorces I hate stories so I'm repeating
again if you're watching this and it's
going to trigger you you're going to go
home and make your wife's life hell
please for the sake of Allah turn it off
go watch something else please yeah if
you're watching it to understand better
that's fine but I'm warning again if
you're gonna watch this and it's gonna
have an impact on you where you're gonna
go home and start causing Havoc please
when I hit a cause destroy your marriage
we're here to help just to give that
disclaimer anything that said here is to
understand both men and women sorry just
to carry on I just need to give that
because yeah it's yeah I know many
brothers that they're like I don't want
to ask about her past because I'm scared
that her past might change my view or
possession of her but they can't control
themselves
why can't you just forgive and forget
why does it bother you so much maybe
it's just one enough listen look I'm not
gonna lie to you yeah I'm not going to
be here to please anybody
I may I may forgive but I won't forget
okay and I can't listen me me personally
I can't listen if I if I'm trying if I'm
talking to a girl and I ask about a
person she goes oh I heard like two free
boyfriends or after this this guy that
guy
even if she's like the perfect girl for
me my whole perception and view of her
would change dramatically but as a woman
it's like in Islam it's not your
business sister I agree with you and a
woman who discloses her sins to you if
if she did live in a sinful past she
does not need to tell you or expose her
since so whether you are none the wiser
or you find out from a different Source
then that is your test between you and
Allah at the end of the day because
as Allah says Those Who conceal somebody
else's sin Allah will conceal yours on
the day of judgment so it applies to a
woman as well who has had a past
that is a very very good point however
in my opinion
is better the woman if the guy asks the
woman a question is better woman to
honest before marriage
so the guy can accept or reject because
if the guy finds out during marriage
then you're going to get divorced you
get divorced no no no but it's bad you
don't get married then you get married
and the guy finds out during marriage
and you get divorced what's better again
you get married again
why does a woman's past matter if she
has gone to
him the most merciful and has asked for
forgiveness from the most forgiving and
you who are just a man cannot forgive
that that's the definition you know did
you understand that yeah
let's go to Gabriel and then I'll say
something
so I get two questions yesterday
and today I got a question from brother
and sister and I get it often I'm trying
to think
um they've been asking okay make a video
about this and the brothers are asking
how do I know
if my wife is a virgin or how how would
I know if my wife
uh on the marriage night how can I tell
she's a virgin and the sisters will ask
how can I hide it
because I have committed sin I have
Community now
um
so so these are like yesterday and today
I received these two and I've been
receiving it but it's just so so it's
very common it's very common very common
so the sister was asking like okay
literally I was I believe her that she's
very repented and all the sisters who
have asked this question and I also
believe the brothers are very concerned
as well who have asked and they're very
sincere yeah
um so the sisters
will basically say it's part of the way
one sister frame knows that am I am I
done like do I still have hope of
marrying a righteous man or not right
like well Allah forgive me and from a
perspective the Sharia indeed
right because uh the personal The Sinner
who makes doll bites like the one who's
never committed sin that's number one
right so from the Shira perspective but
see here we have to understand again
what is fitra and what is Sharia
the human being is different than the
Sharia the Sharia was revealed upon the
fitra to fine-tune it so human being has
to hold themselves
for example sin is built in US Allah
is given us the two paths right yes this
is something that Allah is built where
did the ability to sin come from Allah
has creators in such a way right word
this these things that we're talking
about oh man cannot do this when we
cannot that this is fitra Allah is
created us in such a way yeah
Sharia was revealed with the account to
fine tune our fitra to make us go beyond
and hold ourselves so let's say you have
this mindset we're like no I'm not going
to accept this no it's like but Allah
said for example that
this person's forgiven can you take
yourself to that level to mold your
fitra
to become so strong and so submissive
that you can Overlook that that's the
question and the reality is that yeah
some Cancer Cannot exactly and the
question here is that is a man to blame
to not want that now just so you sisters
understand where we're coming from
and it will resonate home and sister
soul please forgive me for doing this
but uh polygamy
um the reason I'm saying this because if
you look at polygamy it's something
yeah yeah exactly
so if you think about polygamy to your
fitra it's like ah no way
this is how we feel about a woman is
like yeah yes and then and then with us
a woman's past is like but for you guys
it's like why do you understand just so
just to give some perspectives on
something how we feel like how you guys
feel about polygamy and how we feel
about the past awesome
no not one is
um
uh for example a past is a past it's not
you can't correlate the two I don't
think the woman's fast can be that she
was married four times no that's I'm not
talking about it I never talked about
that we discussed that okay no I know
but the thing is what we're saying is
that talking about being married and
talking about somebody who had zinner
four times more to a man let's be honest
is that the same if I if I married a
woman and she was married three times
my concern is not I wouldn't have a
concern of I don't know maybe it's just
me yeah I would be thinking oh Bro
you've got married no no problem the
estimate other concerns
yeah who has had dinner okay because
that's all she knew she wasn't married
okay she's converted to some other guy
supposedly yeah but okay the Sharia look
they're very clearly the Sharia says
look for example that Allah says
only marry the who was someone who's
Italian yeah now the point point is this
dog but if they repent we need to
understand this doesn't mean the one
who's committed is doomed to marry
someone's coming soon I'm sorry let's
make this clear the question is though
should a man have a right to ask but
what he's saying is that this is
something that bothers us men
saying what I'm saying is it and again
my opinion
if you're a man that's slept around as
well yourself I think it's a bit
hypocritical for you to then start
question in the go but if you're a guy
like me alhamdulillah yeah good good boy
it's not it's not the same it's not the
same people are gonna hate me for this
it's not the same if if my mother Sharia
by the way sorry in front of the Sharia
the capital punishment is the same yes
let's just disclaim it so before people
I know people getting on a mad one yeah
in the Sharia if a woman or a man comes
zinner you get if you're not married you
get
um flocked 100 times if you are married
you get you know the capital punish you
don't go to details in the Hereafter the
punishments the same in the sight of
Allah
however please listen to me carefully
statistics statistics shows by the way
that when a woman has more than one
sexual partner her successful marriage
goes from 80 to 20 percent number one it
doesn't affect a man more than it does a
Woman by the way the statistics show and
it's very interesting it goes with the
Sharia if your man has been intimate
with four people partners and by the way
we're not encouraging anyone if a
brother's not here I can go please shut
up yeah please shut your mouth nobody's
telling you yo I can go come as you know
no no what we're seeing is the
psychological consequences are not the
same that's what we're saying just to be
clear does that make sense I repeat
again the Sharia both of them up to
punishment but the impacts that it has
on a woman is not the same impact has on
a man can I cannot reply to this so
there's um this couple like uh words
that we've thrown around which are we
obviously don't have time but we have
more episodes to discuss 100 I want to
understand and I want to understand the
book of fitra and all this stuff that is
within the fitra and classified as the
fitra because I don't know where that
that book exists you know that book that
says oh that's the fitter of the man
that's the fitter of the woman
I do understand there are certain things
that we can say that man are known for
throughout history I know I know A Book
Like That by the way certain things that
man do
um and there's also certain things what
the Quran talks about certain things
that women do and how women feel and
then sociologically how females are
regarded or seen uh for example the
story of Aisha
where she was accused to yes done yes a
certain thing and then the ayat of like
the flogging of the man or the person
who accuses a chaste woman so like I
understand there are these certain
things but like
I feel like the Quran what the Quran
really talks to a lot and the majority
of times it encourages people to do it's
like
the innate person themselves you know
like it I don't think that
the idea of like dividing man and female
for example this idea that
a man who is promiscuous
um is less tainted than a womanless
promiscuous I mean you talk about fitra
and you talk about Sharia but what about
like spiritually a man who slept a lot
around spiritually I don't think he's
going to be any healthier than the woman
has not sorry that's not true on a
spiritual level no that's not true no no
I'm saying honest spiritual level of
course
if you are staying if you're saying that
if you're saying yes enough but if
you're saying the Sharia if you've seen
the Sharia punishes the sin the same
thing same then spiritually not the same
thing no no sorry bro sorry sorry no no
no no no listen guys according to you
according to him no no no no no to him
we're talking about cultures
literally very simple we're talking
about Fitness you're just on the same
scale meaning that sister no there's
consequences sister the consequences
thank you it's not only on sisters as
well no sister sister I repeat again
yeah Allah has created us yes amen by
Nature okay you agree but disagree but
the man that slept with 20 years
for example I'm talking in terms of
consequences and the same applies for
sisters okay can I can I answer the
question the punishment for both of them
I said that I said that very clearly I
said that the woman is not like them
yes in everything from there
it might not be the same in a
psychological sense or a physical sense
however on a spiritual sense it is the
same because the punishment would bear
the same consequence spiritual sense
cannot be quanticized okay when you talk
about spiritual what do you mean by that
you're talking about in a lawful way
if you're asking me there are a disease
way so in the west we are living in a in
a sense where you know we are
hypersexualized so in a in in a
spiritual way we are all battling that
same uh shaytan or that same sin and
that realistically is really putting us
down into that place and it actually is
very sad because a lot of girls who do
grow up in the west and it's taboo to
talk about sex so it's taboo to discuss
or you know a lot of the girls are not
getting the guidance that they're
supposed to get and they fall in this
thing that oftentimes they are regretful
for it and then when they do end up
growing up it's like you you learn your
spiritual
um aware Awakening you have a spiritual
awakening you learn certain things from
the Deen and you start to have that
Journey yourself and then after that
you're then vilified by the men that are
supposed to protect you and in in Islam
we we are supposed to be protected
there's two things because he asked
Gabriel asked me okay so this is
finished we finished sorry well nothing
it's not finished
no because he asked the question
spiritually what does that even mean
I'll tell you exactly what that means
the prophet Muhammad said that the
person who sins and continues this thing
what happens to the soul a DOT appears
yes no you are saying that the man who
sins and does the sin there's less dots
appearing on this no no no you're
misconstrueable I'm so sorry
you're using two separate things hold on
I'm asking you I'm trying to answer my
asking there's enough for the prophet
because he says that he says not the
woman he says the believer the believer
who commits Zina what happens is that
his Iman is lifted from him lift it from
him yes are you saying that the Imam the
woman is lifted differently from them no
that's what I'm trying to say no that's
not a point that's the point
the guys guys one second let's go let's
go let's go to Back to Basics okay let's
go back let's read rewind one second
thank you
rewind okay let me make something clear
I'm not here to say that any man should
go and shun a woman and make her feel
rubbish for a past I'm not saying that
that's trying to make this a productive
show I'm not trying to be like yeah you
go no I'm not saying that I'm just
saying can our sisters who are watching
here and that Tom understand us men
where we're coming from that's what
we're seeing please understand I didn't
wake up today and say you know what I
feel like this woman connect if I can
just feels as well if I can the same
feeling that you got me personally
coming from it sorry yeah from a certain
education from a certain background you
fight all your life to preserve yourself
you don't want to have some to marry
someone that went and slept all around
we look at that as well of course not to
agree with what the brother said with
the black you know you were talking
about psychological consequences you
were talking about that as well yes the
black dots are all the effect of the
sins on our human beings we're missing
the point you're right that's a very
good point I know but I need to
summarize your but the thing is if I can
just if I can just because I'm
let me just make this point I repeat
again in the Sharia the Zenna the two
people is the same the capital
punishment is the same and the Hereafter
is the same when a person commits a sin
there's a black dot it's the same please
understand and hear me clearly in the
heart it's the same
spiritually no please guys I haven't I
haven't finished I haven't finished
thank you so what I'm saying is this
what I'm saying is this the consequences
are not the same we're not talking about
the Hereafter
thank you thank you sister may Allah
bless you now for a man like we talked
the fact that where he was coming from I
resonate with that another man the whole
reason now is that cable residents we
don't want to go hey that's weird man
why don't you think like that every man
that's watching this when you went to
Birmingham and did that and you asked
him I did a social experiment in
Shepherd's Bush I said to them
two options a woman who's had 20
intimate partners and is a
multi-millionaire and the other woman
who is a virgin
he's a virgin but he's broke 90 of them
said Brooke broke broke now the point
I'm trying to see is the following I'm
just going to finish so we can
understand yeah the consequences are not
the same meaning
can I finish well I'm sorry I know I
talk talk about if I make this point
then I'm going to take a step back just
so I'm not misconstrued I do I like I do
my wife says that as well yeah so the
thing is this year now what I'm saying
is this because men are created
polygamous Allah had to put in our fitra
that being with four wives that will not
have a psychological impact on us
because otherwise why would Allah tell
us to be why would Allah creators in a
certain way wish that if we indulge in
that thing is going to have a
psychological impact on us hello number
one
um even if it's done around with these
consequences of course but it's still
it's wrong but for a woman because your
monogamous by your nature that Allah has
created your life and has given you
higher the prophet peace be upon him
said a woman's intimate desires are 99
greater times greater but it's keeps it
in check therefore I'm summarizing I'm
finished therefore when a woman has
intimate Partners it has a greater
psychological impact on her than it does
to a man please bring your evidence if
you disagree
you listed a lot of things and then he's
working his way back yes I just I didn't
have a budget wanted you to Define he
said consequences but you never defined
okay so consequences is for example okay
outcomes use the word outcome okay okay
sorry sorry sorry okay okay outcomes no
but is outcomes consequences in
anyway when it comes to
pet show that if a woman has more than
one intimate sexual partner her married
her success marriage marriage to be
successful drops from 80 to 20 percent
due to the latest that due to the man
being insecure about her no no no it's
just basically her past her could have
been more than one into my partner she
is less likely to be pair bonding her
pair bonding abilities are these are
studies studies online now when it comes
to a man they realize which was very
interesting at the fourth Mark yeah then
it's there's a kind of a decline but
it's not as worse as a woman that's what
I'm saying but the outcomes are
different now what I would like to say
there's uh we got to make the
distinction between how things should be
meaning how we should behave as Muslims
yeah uh doubt made a very very good
point about the knock the soda the black
dot you know what I mean the outcomes or
the the consequences of the sin let's
use that word are the same yeah that's
that's all I was saying heart will be
stained by the Black Dog until the point
because
Allah says it becomes like this this
heart that's uh discovered uh but
the way a man reacts so let's go back to
Haram if he is polygenous for example
um he's gonna the the outcomes of that
polygen is going to be different than if
a woman
has had multiple Halal Partners in there
that's why I wanted to fix there's a bit
of a difference right I know we're
talking about sorry I know we're talking
about sins yeah and I'm gonna just add
to that but what I was saying is within
the Halal if a man is in polygeny for
example has had multiple partners wives
halal
the outcomes of that interaction are not
detrimental actually it helps a man even
sexually even there's a spike in the
okay for the woman if she's been married
again Halal yeah the pair bonding issues
are going to be there yeah the studies
are clear uh putting that aside when it
comes to the sins
when it comes to the sin so development
said very clearly very clearly because
again there is what we should be like as
Muslims how many people are in the
should Department that's right that's
right not many and how real it's like
al-watia which is the reality and how it
should be the Sharia Allah you'll find
two things within the Quran he's Allah
tells us pray do this do that but the
reality is most people are not to do it
what do you how do you deal with that
right so that what I might have said
clearly
sister us should I tell my husband
should I disclose this say no you should
not disclose your sins right should I
lie
what kind so the system what if he finds
out what if he finds out that's that's
interesting so what do what do sisters
do because I'll be honest with you I
would personally say no I would
personally say to any sister yeah it's
like I think there's a story but I don't
know how authentic is yeah that a man
came and said is that shall I disclose
it and he said are you are you mad don't
ever disclose it yet but it's different
for a woman isn't it it is but that the
thing is you shouldn't know for a woman
he was talking about his daughter her
value is so much more exactly so I would
personally say it messes up there's so
many more consequences yes so I would
personally say like the scholar status
as well that it should it should be
hidden to a point because at the end of
the day this is how we are created look
why we didn't wake up and say you know
what let me be like this this is how we
are so the thing is
I think the difference between men and
women in a sense is
men will operate from a place of ego
when it comes to that information
particularly of a woman's past it's
because of my ego can't accept it you
know I can't allow yeah insecurity right
because again a woman is a sense a woman
is a man's sense of Pride right in a way
whether you like to accept it or not
aside from Islam but as well like
growing up in the UK like body count was
a huge thing like so boys have that
mentality oh well yeah I have it as well
yeah of course women have it as well
women do have it but it's not as much
situation for me is very important what
we're talking about sorry what do you
say what's important because she was
saying like body count let's say you
guys extremely practicing now he's super
practicing
okay okay he's five years
okay so this will go to our second kind
of segment yeah is do you care about a
man's past or his future so for example
if a man comes and he says
um I used to live a party life Etc
whatever it may be I had some
girlfriends
um but I've repented I've totally
repented I'm a new person and he's
successful is God fearing he has taqwa
he's he's got whatever it may be yeah
would you say no to him or would you say
yes to him there's like what's from here
okay okay so so he's changed he's saying
you know what look I've repented I've
changed my ways before clubbing party
and whatever it may be but now
I just want to focus on my future for me
I don't just look at the sexual aspects
of things I think if a man can you
answer the question within that yeah
yeah yeah for me yeah it wouldn't be a
problem for me
yeah
aspects of sin it's not sexual is not
the only sin that exists not for you yes
for us yes yeah but for for a woman if a
man was committed
of course
I'm not forgiving that okay
I will follow the same steps that the
Toba Journey okay meaning like what did
you do to stop from your past did you
cut did you keep ending he's a new guy
that you remember that Allah is not only
has a very specific meaning that means
not only Allah gets rid of the sin but
he gets rid of the effect of the sins of
ham Allah and that's a beautiful that's
why we say goes back to the names of
Allah fine subhanallah
answers and the fact that Allah we are
talking about consequences on pair
bonding psychological how we can mess up
with men and women because you're only
insisting on the woman but I think that
the men that had a relationship who said
that the consequence of the sin where
did you find that no you were saying
like um
none of the effects of the same that's
why
because I was asking the teacher what's
the difference between the other and she
said like it's not only the sin is the
possible effect the addiction
what we're saying is the sin of course
the sin the sin is
the specialist Allah
we believe that the sins are turned into
Good Deeds we understand that but if
you're talking from the expert because
it's understand about the message it's
important to remind the sisters and the
brothers consequences leave you because
that's the the whole
um beauty of
the consequences remains with human
beings right so of course the
consequences will be lifted if Allah
Wills but of course if if a man who
doesn't want to accept it then that's
his business I would just be advising
women not to go with men who don't
accept the fact that you are also a
human being
it's not that what they don't accept
the answers if you notice I think all of
you have said so far that you would be
okay as long as it's made Toba he's
followed the Toba Journey right but why
wouldn't you be okay
guys guys just men men look men if our
Prophet Muhammad
was able yeah
of course
if our men are meant to be striving to
be like the sahaba why can you not then
accept it great question great question
guys guys can I get the answer for me
one second one second please just answer
the question please sister I'm sorry
just the question that I asked sure the
answer to that would be yes I would
accept him sister
[Music]
um I think how would I get to that quick
like point where I find out all these
things about him no no he just come to
you and said you know what I used to
have this pass Etc he's someone that
you're getting to know for marriage and
then he says this and would you accept
it would you like now
um clubbing and none of yourself
clubbing I know I'll give the chat in
life and I've repented now and I'm he's
a successful guy God fearing taqwa is a
good person now so would you judge him
by his past or his future well I
wouldn't judge him by his future I'm
just judging by the person he is right
now okay so he's a good film so yeah
then yeah okay good yes really quickly
is that um
I think in a way for example if you're
going to be asking somebody questions
right don't
um ask them a question if the tables
were reversed you couldn't answer
yourself or you'd feel ashamed to answer
because that's kind of being a little
bit of a hypocrite
um at the same time I think it's kind of
good that men have that in them because
it then teaches our sisters to be
careful of our steps to not exactly sort
of loosen ourselves and not forget who
we are supposed to be yes we didn't have
that yes nobody would know exactly and
that's the reason why we've covered this
topic is so that the reason we did this
topic is so because the the the Western
world is sending this no you're like a
man go out there yeah by the way even
men watching this is Haram it's a major
sin there's what we're not saying for
men it's oh go have fun my friend no
we're not saying that we're just saying
the consequences are so much greater for
a woman so that's why we're seeing that
do not think because some sisters think
no and it is look let me be honest with
you this was something I had to die I
remember I was thinking about this
hypocrisy man well my other man I was
thinking is he probably deep inside I
was like I'm a man and I'm like that
bothers me but I was like I come from a
jail and I was like do you have the
right to and then I realized to myself
you know what it sounds important but
you can't we're looking for that again
the point is though I realized to myself
that you know what the Dynamics are
really different it's not that we choose
to so therefore understand that when it
comes this may be different but the
diseases are sure and that's the thing
about before we say that make sure let
me let me turn this on ahead yeah
because we keep forgetting that marriage
and this is to do with you know Masha
you're saying about how we influenced by
the environment that we live in marriage
is not an individualistic act that you
do by yourself especially for sisters we
ask systems would you accept that yeah
maybe they would but with the father
because the father who marries off their
daughters if I had someone I knew this
guy has been around the block
am I I did all my due diligence to keep
my daughter and herself as well with our
own emissions she tries to keep herself
pure I would reject the guy and say you
get lost thank you you see and the
reason why I'm saying this is because
you know hasn't been Ali the son of
Hassan he was like notorious known to be
you know quite uh
is it authentic okay you're talking
about like marriage-wise yeah yeah there
was known to have so many white like
managers
no I'm not no I'm not sick I'm not
saying I'm just saying that there was
one sahaba uh Hassan approached him so
much and he had kind of refused because
of he was worried about his daughter so
this is the question I'm asking if you
know yeah if you ask you a question
right if if and I've seen a lot of um
people asking this question online
um regarding Andrew Enrique but if
someone like him or someone who's been
very promiscuous right and you know that
this guy was a wild man yeah would you
accept him for your for your daughter to
to be married I I say it straight I
wouldn't I wouldn't accept someone like
that if if I know that my daughter think
about that's a good one
are you coming from an angle of a man
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
no no no no no no no no no no no that's
his point so he's saying like men men
are like that for the women but also men
are like that man as well that's that's
the point so that's why I was trying to
say so many questions so this point is
very very smart yeah so his point is men
on just like that for women men are like
that for other men as well so whenever
it has been different for the daughters
but for some she's someone your wife is
someone as daughter so the Hypocrites
well you see the there might be that the
Father the Wally is going to reject it
yeah yeah exactly yeah yeah that's true
that's true that's true and it's amazing
because
[Music]
the reality is that we're dealing with
these situations today these problems
are there today most men are not going
to accept how do you fix that but
brother we you are the absolutely right
question and I was going to go back to
that point you said like this is the
fact this is what we should be and this
is the fact the fact like but in every
Masters in our life we go back to what
to the Sunnah yes like you mentioned the
most secure and the most healthier
example was the prophet why no one talks
about that brother the Sunnah is this
Allah is the same account but no we want
to bring out but they're talking about
the politics
no no it's not sinful it's not no no no
you can't say that it's a person I would
encourage but we should always go back
to yes one second and it's funny how
many brothers will question the sister
and they are the biggest like they have
like and I'm saying very close
there may be in some relationships still
yes it's a sexual double standard but
that's what I'm saying like Allah
doesn't like hypocrisy we have to be
something
it's a form of hypocrisy when in the
eyes of Allah is the same sins it's a
contradiction it's what's called in
Arabic okay cannot be because hypocrisy
nifak is something totally totally
different and it's a sexual double
standard it's a double standard a man
will happen 100
and it's because it's it's somehow it's
linked to our biology
I'm sorry in the white communities how
is it the most respected
okay we need to please you've got one
and a half minutes sister express
yourself I will say I don't think it is
uh
in your biology I do think it's an
ideology that's been perpetuated within
the male community so oh you know women
if you've had a past no no no because
there are there is history of
pre-islamic and even uh in Islamic
history where women have been previously
with with with other men and then
they've now been able to marry
successfully and in fact it even shows
that women are very good wives and they
do
um you know repent for whatever they've
done and they become a very successful
relationship and even sometimes better
so I do think the responsibility lays on
men to stop perpetuating that a woman is
stained when she has Sinners
she's got 30 seconds when you go to the
sorry I have to stick by the rules okay
yeah like a woman is not stained by her
past she's not got this like big big
sign saying you know I've done lots of
Madness but again and also I do think
um our Muslim men are hypocrisy
Hypocrites because they not all of them
but some men in our Muslim communities
are hypocrites because they will go for
a reverted woman who is either from the
white background who's done an absolute
Madness and accept her but when it is a
Muslim woman who is also a human being
who's done certain things because of the
western society and they will not accept
her many of the converse sisters get
divorced within the first five years
it's not true they might they have this
they idealized them they have this whole
wow comrade sister but when you analyze
the uh the problems that come out of
that most of the many of them but let me
just add one sorry see the process tell
them you're writing what you said again
there should be a standard that matches
the Sunnah but the reality is even if
let's say we would fix all men to think
like that that will follow some of the
Professional Center right
um the men are still going to have a
choice within that Sunnah because the
Sunnah is prescriptive it's not fought
for a man to marry a a virgin or a
divorcee so the process when he spoke
about virginity that time he actually
explained you should have married a
virgin because yeah what it wasn't sure
what's your major river and says and
I'll sorry to go into a little bit of
detail here but he said so that you may
play with her yeah and she'll be playing
with you here it goes back to sexuality
and molding as opposed to her having
previous Partners previous experiences
less pair bonding so the men in general
did the process of send a married
version he married one virgin
yeah okay so you see but the process
same again he understands the fifth from
the men when given two choices what are
manga Insurance look at your fitra all
of you have said I will accept this yes
if you went for all of us here and by
the way just again aggressive disclaimer
yeah and once again if there is a sister
that's watching this yeah because it's
pertaining to that I'll repeat again I
mean this is there's eyes on the Quran
as well we are not saying that you want
to commit sins look you might be better
than many many sisters out there yeah
you don't see so sorry you're
contradicting what you just asked no no
no you just said you just said you
wouldn't accept the sister
just a clarify system no I understand
I don't blame you no no no I don't blame
you for it came across like 100 100
you're right just to clarify yeah what
I'm saying is this here genuinely if you
ask it's not a social construct if you
put all of us if I was the only man on
this planet and there was no men within
my filter I would be like I would prefer
that that doesn't mean woman as well
that that doesn't mean yeah no not for a
woman for a woman if there was no one on
this planet and news on your own you
would still say okay I'll judge you by
his future nobody's past with me I would
say no buy his buy her past so just to
give some clarification yeah is that I'm
saying I would prefer that however if I
go and come across a sister who may have
made a part a mistake in a past Allah
witness here I'm personally this
personal to me yeah I would say if it
was one mistake genuinely I would say
you know what
no I'm not talking about divorce I'm
talking about yeah I come from yeah
bearing things in mind Etc deep down
I'll be like I wish it didn't but again
I would say you know what to me
personally if it's too personally to me
I can't I'll be like I can't because I
don't want to cause hustle to you and
myself so I'm just giving that
disclaimer but this doesn't mean that
sister could be 100 times better than a
sister who has never been with somebody
I want to make that disclaimer we're not
here saying we're just seeing like my
sister said she believes it's a social
construct that no it's because of an ego
for me
Allah is my witness and all of them will
testify here is not Sister We're created
like this just the way you guys are
created that when your husband gets a
second wife you lose it well at least
there's a misunderstanding I need to
clarify no it's very important for abuse
my dear sister
yeah and what I'm saying is that the way
we are created we would prefer look this
is the reason why I do this Billy give
me example you would prefer if I asked
you guys would you prefer okay okay okay
would you prefer that your husband has a
second wife or one you say I prefer one
second it will really hurt me I'm seeing
with us we would prefer there is no past
at all yeah however yes yes preference
however you cannot go and be like oh if
a sister get arguments I'm getting some
assistance of a marriage she goes you
know what
um I was I I commit two times whatever I
would never ever say you're worse than
me I would say you know what you are
maybe 100 times better than me and you
know the woman who was an adulterer who
was caught and they they give you the
capital punishment yeah and the blood
was splattered onto one sahaba's feet
you know what he did he was like this
the process if you knew her repentance
would be sufficient for the whole of
Medina Goosebumps
Goosebumps I'm saying this said her
repentance is maybe sufficient for the
whole of Medina yeah
so just just finished yes yes so the
point is this yet we I would never look
at the system be like you know what I
would say you're probably 100 times
better than me but personally on my feet
I it's just do you think I'm trying to
say can I command can I command oh sorry
it's really not against you just so I
could have a say to you yes
um just wanted to say that we are
naturally quite curious creatures we're
crazy like that am I very judgmental as
well as much as we try not to be
so when you're trying to pick a spouse
you're going to and this is for men and
women you you can you're going to look
at it as fast and you're going to look
at its future and her future because the
fast the past will determine what kind
of character they had How They Carried
themselves and the Future Would
determine what kind of spouse and
parents they make
for example completely unrelated if I
was to say invest into cryptocurrency
I'm going to look up Bitcoin and see
exactly how it's been fluctuating I'm
really not going to throw my money in
there I want to look at his past I'm
going to look at the investment that
I've made and others have earned before
I invest in that and we invest in
spouses and in you know in their future
in our future Now Children's future that
goes on forever that's a lifelong
investment so I think it's not
necessarily not necessarily wrong to ask
somebody about their past but it depends
on what you are asking and that is where
the fine line is and you've got to make
sure don't cross it exactly and another
person said sisters hide it and it's
simple if he says you know I would like
to just say make an excuse he said you
know I would I would want a wife who's a
virgin and who doesn't go work make the
work in exclusive you know what blah
blah you want something I want to work
don't go and say oh hide it I'll
personally say hide it as much as
possible because I just wanted to about
15 minutes yeah yeah please yeah I just
wanted to command you because yeah like
comment do you mean yeah okay yes
because I read that because I know
personally and this is like off you know
people don't need to know I know you
personally so I know the decisions
you've made in the past which go against
the things that you believe no that
um decision that you made in the past if
you were to place them with what you
said today they would be the opposite so
I command yeah right no it's good
because you're saying basically look
this is how men's are despite of that I
did choose to be married to someone
who's been married before I mean so
that's
um no no I said I would I would want to
like I would have no problem if yeah
that's what I'm saying so the fact that
you're saying that but at the same time
you're saying I've always had that
position bro no no but I've read that
because you're not a match documentary
no no I read that because it's like
you're not just you know I mean you're
not just backing up a point because it's
to do with you in your backing up a
point because it's a bigger picture
right
um but like I'd say because because this
is the bitter truth yeah and like and
one thing I would love to see because
you see so for example a fresh and fair
or Andrew Taylor anyone they have these
podcasts what happens is that these are
like hubs of Education right people
learn from these things so like yes I
understand that man not and honestly if
he was to ask me I'll be honest look if
if there is a female and I know she had
like a crazy past it would be even for
me it would be difficult I'll be honest
that's what we're saying I'll be it
would be difficult for me to be like
yeah because I'll look at her sometimes
and be like to me this this is the
experience yeah like man have like this
weird weird ways you know you know where
that's coming from though just not to
cut you up she said you know where
that's coming from yeah is as men we
need to understand and I'm very very
sorry like
is that for a man the act of intimacy is
being done too so because of a man
psychological he's like so just yeah for
a man we're like wow like
just yeah yeah
understand a man's psychology just where
we come from that's all I want well
that's my I don't want it like yeah so
like but saying this and this I think
this is the main difference between us
and like the rest of all the communities
who are struggling at the moment is that
we have Islam and that we have the
prophet Muhammad
emulate like what what did the prophet
say like when the Sabbath when he used
to tell the sabbas there will come a
time where people would not know left
from right and people gonna it's like
stick to my Sunnah like all time like
this this platform because and I love
what what you're doing mashallah you're
doing it already like you educate people
right change people's mind because it's
not that it's so hardwired that it can't
change because you mentioned something
very beautiful earlier you said that and
I know this as well that in the Somali
Community for a divorcing woman to get
married is very easy yeah so clearly
there's something within them yes that
they have in fact
they're people of Quran a lot of Africa
countries that are predominantly Muslim
yeah this is not an issue it's not an
issue so you have to look it should be
like that the
subcontinents where this might be a a
bigger issue you know where is
we remember times
okay I I don't know if it's always a bad
thing like every um you were saying
about uh amongst the Asian Community
there are certain things that we may see
as bad but it has preserved them for a
very very long time but I think for
people who live in a diaspora it's for
us to start to negotiate certain things
you know and starting to realize that
okay this might be the nature of man but
the circumstances that we're in now
there's so many females who are not
married
do we have to adjust ourselves according
to this area I think the bits of Truth
is tell the system please uh we need to
speak more to our daughters and our sons
yes and start our educational levels and
stop being so shy to have these
conversations with them because in
schools it's no shyness there there is
no shyness they are feeding your kids
exactly these topics all the time
they're going to be organizing them
children who are doing these things and
if we're so shy trust me in school
they're not being hid away from other
things and they are going to go out and
do these things and regret it in the
future there are social media
influencers who actually used to teach
girls to be free who are now turning
away from it and saying actually I
didn't value myself so teach your
daughters to love and value themselves
and boundaries irrespective of a man's
opinion they should love and value
themselves so that they do not have to
regret with little creative yes you're
talking about kids but I want to talk as
well about Muslim women you know that
sometimes attempted by immense by
meeting Muslims think they are protected
by
think that
someone please okay and I want to talk
um you talked about kids but even our
sisters are indicated with the fact that
you put boundaries protect themselves
from they think like Xena is only for
the non-muslims or the non-practicing no
Xena happens in our community my sisters
like I always like advise protect your
dignity protect your honor at all cost
and another thing I want to say and I
joined the brother we need to make our
criteria the Sunnah we need to align
them and we talking about it like it's
undoable no it's like that it's the fit
that I know not a long time ago we used
to bury girls and alhamdulillah we are
far far from that it was the culture it
was the norm it was normal what you will
say like it's it's normally exactly we
think like that but is the lack of fit
is the lack of an Islamic yeah exactly
number I'm saying those Muslims changed
but what I'm trying to say it was at
that time
this is what
one thing I want to say we need to wrap
up yeah one thing can you imagine if men
were judged by they passed by women no
I'm sorry I just want to say stop them
from from doing Zina it will stop them
from sinning
if the woman will be judging Brothers by
their past they will be more careful
just like those sisters like you were
saying is protecting them but that's why
I know that's what we're seeing it goes
back to the future
that's but women don't do because you
know you know that was talking about we
should yeah no no no no no but this is
now this becomes a social construct
because you're like let's do it now
you're coming together with your
citizens
please understand something what you're
doing is a social construct let's come
together and put pressure no problem the
point I'm trying to see is the following
we are built it's hard hardwired you
guys are saying let's reprogram that's
the difference which shows which one
which shows what no she's saying we
should
let me be honest when I first came to
Islam I had a shock of the reality show
yeah I used to grill Brothers on this
topic day in day out so yeah literally
what like how men think do you remember
that yeah exposing well like day in day
out you know why because we say to our
brothers we're not here to get easy
right and let me tell you one thing you
know we talked about how there's a
greater consequence for a woman but
there's something we're not talking
about it's interesting yeah to the
brothers that are watching this yeah you
see when you go and and I'm not saying
this is the innocent yeah please listen
to this carefully brother when you go
and try to fool that sister or whatever
to commit to dinner
just imagine this for a second yeah okay
you need to understand that there if
they're on if you're doing that to
somebody else's assistant somebody
else's daughter there are many men like
you who are doing it to your future wife
now future sister listen listen listen
listen listen because when we talk about
these consequences I want you to
understand something if every man listen
to this if every man goes and tricks a
woman or whatever it may be yeah into
this like guess what guess what happens
there's consequences that's the reason
why that's the reason why when you go
and you cry you're not a virgin yeah
proper remember that girl yeah
that is what is happening because there
are Ripple effects and this is what
happens to people oh my sister bro bro
Allah Works in ways that's the way yes
there might be paid bonding issues with
the sisters it's a reality but brother
when you wake up and you're like oh yeah
remember those girls I use with before
it's all happy days for you yeah okay
how about this now so there are
consequences and Allah is the most trust
listen on that inshallah my dear sisters
please forgive us we said anything
crossing the line we just genuinely
doing this like you said we have to talk
about these topics because so we can
educate people yeah and inshallah we can
be a role model that Orthodox Muslims
can come together with talk about issues
that help the people who are watching
inshallah and that is the aim of the
show
um sorry concluding remarks well
conclusion imagine
that actually you know what let's start
with this they're going to say these
misogynistic men who are you know uh
okay it's not from yourself and then
[Music]
I was just gonna say like a message for
women don't write yourselves off if you
uh sinned in the past like we all do we
all make mistakes Allah is the most
forgiving and I personally would say Do
not expose your sins like you don't need
to it's not a man's business to know
your past he should know you for your
presence and what you are now bringing
forward if Allah has forgiven you then
it's not a man's responsibility to take
Allah's responsibility you know
yeah yeah just to remind our brothers as
well I'm gonna go against
self-accountability as well on their own
scene is so crucial and and you know
like to summarize what you were saying I
know I kept throwing you to then as you
do will be done to you so sometimes
subhanallah it's not even the fear of
Allah is the fact that she'd be scared
that something will happen the same to
you don't touch your wife and yes so
just align our criteria to the Sunnah
true but so Brothers watching don't make
criteria would I want this for a sister
don't do it why do you always have to be
you're right like that hurts them more
you're right that what was it more yeah
but don't do it but it's not about some
assistance exactly
there's some doubt for me so yeah pretty
much the same yeah yeah okay okay for
the brothers I would say don't ask
questions that you can't handle the
answers to that's something that is very
important
um sisters some a lot of sisters think
and again it's the guy's fault as well a
lot of sisters think when the guys start
talking to them and they start getting a
bit on the intimate side
um in the marriage let's say because a
lot of these issues cause divorces when
they find out yeah it'll be literally
something like this from what I've seen
from my clients yeah sitting on a
Saturday evening on a couch watching it
that's what give disclaimer bro I know
yeah and then saying like oh how is your
you know we never talked about this yeah
and she thinks sometimes that this is
going to like wow turn them on yes yeah
do you see well I beg you may I bless
you this is why I talk about you know
why because on a sister's point of view
she's thinking oh it's not that deep for
me it's deep for him don't talk about it
and he's gonna pretend the guys like
what the guy is going to do don't worry
honey we will have a pass yeah
so my blood pressure is this place from
experience like is this what you've
heard from clients saying yeah yeah yeah
sister because I will be something like
you know conversation they might be
watching something about yourself and
he's like come on it's okay
she thinks like wow I'm gonna
don't expose your sins don't uh guys
don't ask don't ask questions sisters
don't think that if you're going to give
answers yes and no no no need that make
sure if this this person is like
sticking on you like that yeah
guys sounds bad but be as look as
remorseful as possible that's what I'm
gonna say because the moment you're
light so what I've done it we're gonna
do what I'm interested
see you later Brothers get they sorry
they get hyped up or turned on as long
as she's not your wife as soon as she is
yours yes bro we see that yeah he meets
on the club but she's not going to the
club again yeah
I would say this I would say this and I
think this is something um
I'd say to the sisters look sisters
please help us help us to like
you know exist in this world because we
live in a very very difficult time you
know and like
I think yeah and endow certain things in
society we can't change females will be
judged more harshly that's just the
truth and um
you know and that's
Society now it doesn't mean that it
can't change but like I feel like 50
most really really support the brothers
you know
um and and to be a bit more
understanding that sometimes a lot of
men nowadays as well like because of
like this whole masculinity thing being
like dragged out of us we may not be
able to sort of like behave the way we
we supposed to behave so I'll just any
sister out there like
married woman like just tried to help
and make the situation better because I
think the statement between like the the
woman is judged by her past and the man
is judged by the future I think the most
important thing for Muslims yeah this is
specific for Muslims is that
the Judgment should be that which will
bring you to Jannah
both of you that's like the most
important thing yeah if you and I feel
like this is the problem with us Muslims
nowadays is that we're too entrenched in
like the now if if we could build a
relationship together a vision a vision
together that goes beyond life because
this is this is what makes that's the
difference between the Muslim does the
difference between the quraish and the
Muslim is that sorry yes to build a a
relationship that looks at Jannah like
and this is not listen I'm not trying to
sound cheesy this is the truth you wanna
you wanna talk about reality that's
reality everyone's going to die you're
going to die focus on that which will
bring it to Allah
me I'll just make this short um the the
correct thing and the Islamic thing the
correct thing an Islamic thing is to
keep it private but I would be a
hypocrite and I'll be a liar
I wouldn't ask
and my personal opinion and I'll be
honest doesn't mean I'm right yeah I
would say be honest
and open from the from the get-go the
reason why I say this is because
sometimes give an example if I if a
brother speaks to a girl
and she's not hijabi
and he wants her to be a hijabi and then
they took for like two three months and
he catches his feelings and then when he
asks her after two three months I want a
hijab you can you put on her job and she
says no he's stuck now between I like
this girl
I want to be with her and then he may
sacrifice what he wants or what he did
he should never be in that relationship
anyways but you know what I don't know
but what I'm saying is what I'm saying
is
um it's better yes but you're open again
my opinion that you're open and honest
from the book from the get-go and the
guy says okay I don't want that or you
keep it hidden and then maybe one way or
somewhere he finds out detrimental you
know what that's a discussion on his own
a man have a right to ask the past
that's the discussion
we're gonna have that inshallah on the
next show our wonderful sisters may
Allah bless every single one of you guys
Allah the fact that you guys are here
and sharing this may Allah bless you
guys inshallah really appreciate that
our brothers may Allah bless you hello
brother Gabriel may Allah bless you
inshallah in absolute gem as much as the
world
if you guys liked it you want the same
people to come on inshallah please let
us know comment in the section below
what topics do you want us to discuss
email us want to be in the panel you can
inshallah please forgive us if we hurt
you in any way shape or form which is
genuine genuinely want to understand
opposite gender so we can have a better
future together till next time for
bitter truth assalamu alaikum
and I'll bless you guys I don't want to
be around the bush have you heard of the
Savior Norway Masjid project your
brothers and sisters are Islam yet are
establishing a one of his kind Masjid
Tower and Community Center in the
capital of Norway and they need our
urgent support now every person that
accepts Islam through the center every
river who learns about their Deen and
calls their family to the worship of
Allah you will get the rewards inshallah
so here's what you must do you must
contribute to get your rewards and share
this project imagine you meeting Allah
and receiving the Glad titles of a
palace in Jannah because of this very
Masjid you built with your Sabaka now
you tell me what Greater Joy can there
be than getting a house in Jannah with
Gardens and rivers of Honey walls built
of bricks of gold and silver mortar of
fragrant musk Pebbles of Pearl and
Sapphire and soil of saffron and whoever
enters a house in Jannah will be filled
with joy and will never feel miserable
they will live there forever and they
will never day they will get clothes
that will never wear out and the youth
will never fade away
subhanallah these are the descriptions
of the houses in Jannah that our beloved
Prophet peace be upon Him gave to his
beloved companions would you not want
that for your afterlife click the button
to donate and earn this tremendous
reward inshallah and don't forget to
share the video
[Music]